hey everybody so my name is ashley faith
and i
am the director of semantic search and
knowledge graph at
ebsco information it is a search engine
for a lot of academic research
so if you don't know me i also have a
youtube channel
link up there if you want to go and
check it out or in the description below
either one of those areas and so my
background
is in information science and semantics
in particular so i have my phd in
advanced semantics
and i have been working on search
engines for
at least 14 years at this point so if
you need to see my street cred my
linkedin information is down below
and i would really love to have a
conversation with you
on my channel or over on linkedin if you
are interested
so today i have partnered with
connecteddata london
thank you very much for inviting me to
talk about responsible
a i this is something near and dear to
my heart it is something that i do
believe
all of us need to start thinking about
so that we are not doing more harm than
good
all right so if that sounds interesting
to you please check
the rest of this video out and make sure
to go over to my channel
and see what else i have in store for
you so with that
let's get started all right so
welcome to the second part of
our joint adventure with uh ashley faith
i'm georgia naviotis
and today i'm playing host so i have the
honor of
introducing ashley and before i do
actually
just a couple of words on myself and
what we're doing here
so i'm here wearing my
event organizer hud today so i'm part of
the organizing team of connected data
london
and today ashley is going to talk about
her experience so
lastly the floor is yours oh thank you
something that i am really latching on
to recently
is responsible ai and
how what does that even mean how can we
start to
understand how we can put that into
practice uh
so for me what responsible ai means
is that you are conscious of
the data sources that you are using to
start with
you understand how those data sources
are being processed and by
whom you also understand
what your algorithms are doing with that
data
and the people who are calibrating those
algorithms
and you also really have to understand
your end use case and end users
i think that in machine learning we're
we're all
such data lovers that we want to play
and we want to do things we want to like
you know just experiment but we have to
be careful because
you know if you if you've ever done any
kind of um
big research projects with human
subjects um
you have to have what's called an irb an
institutional review board to to make
sure you're doing
ethical research and
unfortunately when we get out into the
real world we don't have to follow that
anymore and i think
a lot of us it's not that we don't want
to follow it i think it's just we get so
excited we forget
sometimes and so we do have to keep in
mind
there are end users that are going to be
looking at
the results of what we do and not only
that
a lot of the data sources that we are
using
are also generated from real people so a
great example
is in the medical space there are so
many great
open source medical data sources that
you can use
most of those are also ethically sourced
because they are coming from research
institutions
but you also have to realize when you
are gathering
data and you are finding um
trends and and some kind of extraction
of meaning you're talking about those
real
people for instance there is a great
article that just was recently published
i'll link it down below for you and put
it on the screen here
that was conducted with mit and amazon
across
10 major machine learning data sets and
what they found
is these data sets are used
predominantly in the industry and yet
they had at least a 3.4 percent
error rate which is pretty high if these
are being used over and over again in
machine learning
they even said one of the data sources
specifically
had over 54
error rates according to their study
with
a combination of machine and
crowd-sourced information
this is why we have to be more
responsible with our ai
when we are going in and using external
data sources
that's all fine and good but we have to
be responsible enough
to check it and to make sure that it
truly is
of high repute so that when we put that
into our the brains of the machine
that they're not going to reproduce that
error over and over and over again and
when that error
is at the end of the day going to hurt
someone or
hurt the research that will eventually
predominately
cover people that are going to be hurt
by it
that is something that we cannot allow
and we have to get better at
and so taking these steps that we're
going to go over here in a moment
on responsible ai will help us
get a little bit better at at least
understanding the criteria
that we should be measuring when we get
into responsible ai
so we have to make sure that one we we
understand what the data source is right
so we want to make sure that if it was
ethically sourced or not
and there are ways to do that i have a
whole video uh on my channel talking
about that
the second thing you want to do is when
you are looking
at how that data is processed you want
to make sure that
you are not creating a
a context void so if you take all the
context out
you just say this person from this race
or from this background
gets cancer well you missed out on all
that other information that explains
why that happened and that actually
might uncover
more meaningful results and things that
we can have a better
um solution for if we understand the
full
picture and so that's why you can't lose
that context
and my master class at uh connected data
london is going to be talking about that
so if you're interested in that make
sure you check it out
all right so here are my steps for more
responsible ai
or at least things to keep in mind when
doing responsible ai
i am going to be teaching a master class
at connected data london which is
this week and that is april 12th
of 2021 and i am mostly going to be
focusing on
number one two and five in my master
class
but you can certainly check out google's
recommendations which i just had on the
screen
that covers a lot of things that you
would see in number three
and if you are interested in number four
i have
a youtube channel that has many other
videos that are talking about those
topics but
keep it simple when you are talking to
your
end user they are not going to
understand all of your
complicated machine learning ways so
what you have to keep in mind
is explainable ai when you are talking
about what you do
keep these features in mind that you see
on the screen
and really highlight to an end user try
this out with a family member or a
friend and see if they understand what
you're talking about because
people are scared sometimes about what
happens with machine learning
how it can be used for irresponsible
ways
so if we can explain it in simple
down-to-earth terms that people will
understand
it does add more to that trust factor
that we all really need to work towards
in our machine learning all right i mean
playing the devil's advert gate here
that all sounds
great in theory but actually what
happens in practice with
most people that use data sets to to
come to those conclusions
is well it all ends up in being one
big spreadsheet or one big
csv file so how do can you get
context if all you have to work with is
that i mean
you could potentially do it if you had
some
extra metadata or some ways to correlate
your different spreadsheets or your
different csvs but how does that work in
practice
yeah no that's a great question and i
think this is where we all need to
start to build in this responsible ai
practices so you're right a lot of the
data that we have today
there's not much you can do because it
is what it is
but if we all start to understand
what we can do to try to to correct that
a big one is using unique ids if you
have a unique id
it's not it's still anonymous you don't
know the exact person that it connects
to
but you can connect to other metadata
that will help
shed some light or add that context back
another one that is something very
interesting that's going on right now is
personal knowledge graphs where you are
connecting
all this information together through
those unique ids so that you can get
more of that metadata you can understand
the context
of that person or that study or all of
the people that have the same kind of
characteristics
having explainable ai i think is another
piece of this which is
trust so even if you don't have all of
that additional context
is there a way that you can go and mine
and bring it back
bring back the context that might have
been missing from that data source
and the way that you can do that is to
say okay here are the common
characteristics of
of the the personal information that i
have
it's all anonymous but it tells you you
know weight height gender
that sort of thing can i go and mine
from other data sources to get back some
of that context to say okay well i don't
know the exact people this was based off
of but i know the characteristics
so let me go and mine for that from some
of the other data sources and i'm going
to do that ethically
and with responsible ai in mind so i
don't know if there
is something that we can do right away
that can just be like
blink your eyes you know like i dream of
genie and everything is fixed that's not
that's not what i'm talking about here i
think that it's a learning process and
if we're all more aware of it
we can either start to put it into
practice when we gather our own data
or you can find ways to use these
methods to go and gather the context
and use it so that you can continue to
perpetuate responsible ai
sounds like a data integration
case really and um i guess many
people do that even though they may not
aware that they're doing that they may
not
and i wonder if you know if
using semantic technologies you think is
a good idea
i personally think it's it's probably
the best kept
secret about semantic technologies they
really
make your life easier if you want to
integrate data and i think
more people should be secret
absolutely and and that's where that uid
piece comes in i mean that's just one
component of it but
if i can
get at the data and model it in a way
that allows for that integration you
don't have to worry about all of that
you just have to make sure that you can
connect to the api
where all that other data is residing or
if you're using linked data
in your own model um you need to
make sure that the semantics
between the different entities right you
have that trust that those semantics are
there
because then you don't have to worry
about it you don't you have the trust
factor you understand that those were
things that were generated in a way that
are going to add meaning
and it's going to be reliable meaning
and then from there
you have those semantics to just build
off of
that's where that the inferencing has
already been done for you in many cases
a lot of that has to be done from
scratch if you aren't using semantics so
i
i 100 agree with you i think that a lot
of people don't realize
the value of that semantic uh modeling
that is out there but if they did
understand they would know that
it's helping scale the research they're
probably building off of it because
there's a lot of
meaning already retained because of that
semantic modeling
how which which aspects of what you've
talked about so far are you going to
cover in your masterclass so
to make it a bit more tangible so
let's let's say the typical scenario in
which you have
people uh asked to do mastering learning
specific setting that data that comes to
them in the form of
a nice spreadsheet or csv that we all
love
so how does uh domain knowledge
in the in the same in the form of a data
model
it help them deal with that yeah
so what we are going to be specifically
focusing on
is the first portion of that um
responsible ai pathway that i mentioned
and that is
understanding um what is in the data
that you are gathering
or that you already have um and that
would be like these csvs that you're
mentioning and in the class we're
actually going to walk through
how do you first interpret the semantics
if you do
have a semantic set so that could be a
control vocabulary
from um something like
wikidata or you could have something
from
bio portal those often have hierarchies
associated with them
how do you interpret that and use it for
your machine learning that's number one
the second one is way more likely and
that is you have
no structure you just have a list of
stuff
what do you do with it and so in this
class we're going to walk through how do
you make sense of it
and if you have taxonomists in your life
or you have data modelers in your life
use them but more often you probably
don't have someone in your life like
that
and oftentimes you don't have time to
find anyone you really need to quickly
get through this data
so i'm going to show some shortcuts on
how you can interpret that data
add meaning back to it so it can help
your machine learning models not lose
that context
i'm sold
well i'm glad i hope everyone else
enjoys the class too
all right and with all of that said i
hope you join me
at this year's connected data london
where i will be teaching one of the
master classes
focused on how do you use either
taxonomies or knowledge graph
modeling in your machine learning
practices so that you don't
lose all the contacts or trying to get
some of that context back so that your
machine learning
is as robust as it can be alright i
really hope you enjoyed that
make sure you like and subscribe and
make sure you come over and check out my
channel as well
thank you very much and i'll catch you
next time